so viel steht fest der sommer 2018 war
bisher an normal warm jetzt sagt eine
neue prognose voraus das ist auch in den
nächsten vier jahren solche hitze
extreme geben wird und zwar gehäuft denn
zur globalen klimaerwärmung kommt eine
natürliche klimaschwankungen dazu die
zeit zu führen könnte dass sich die erde
in den nächsten fünf jahren noch stärker
erwärmen wird als bisher vorausgesagt
wie das internationale forschungsteam
auf diese prognose kommt und was wir
wirklich in den kommenden jahren zu
erwarten haben das alles und noch viel
mehr jetzt in kriegs um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen jede wird immer
wärmer dieser trend ist klar ebenso klar
ist dass wir menschen einen großteil
dazu beitragen
denn durch unsere co2 emissionen heizen
wir dem klimawandel so richtig ein fast
jedes jahr werden neue klima rekorde
erreicht und wenn der extreme wie dürren
und starkregen häufen sich die
hitzewelle in diesem sommer ist auch ein
beispiel dafür wir haben darüber
berichtet aber forschungsteams weltweit
sind sich auch einig darüber dass nicht
alle veränderungen des klimas auf uns
menschen zurückzuführen sind denn das
klimasystem der erde ist extrem komplex
und immer wieder mal treten natürliche
schwankungen auf das wetterphänomen el
niño ist ein beispiel dafür aber es gibt
noch zahlreiche weitere die wir mit
unserem klima modell nur schlecht
vorhersagen bzw überhaupt erfassen
können genau dieses problem ist ein
internationales forschungsteam aus
frankreich und großbritannien jetzt
angegangen
sie haben ein neues statistisches modell
entwickelt das genau solche schwankungen
vorhersagen soll das besondere dabei ist
das modell ist lernfähig anders als
klimasimulationen die wir bislang kennen
als datengrundlage wurden die
veränderungen der globalen
mitteltemperatur 'nen und der
meeresoberfläche vom zwanzigster und dem
beginnenden einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
zu grunde gelegt den zug kamen die daten
aus zehn verschiedenen klimasimulationen
das modell namens pro gast suchte in
diesem datenwust gezielt nach klimadaten
die der aktuellen situation eine daraus
ermittelte es die wahrscheinlichkeit für
eine bestimmte klimaentwicklung von dem
ergebnis war das forschungsteam selbst
äußerst überrascht denn zur probe hatten
sie es zunächst
einmal eine prognose für die
vergangenheit erstellen lassen nämlich
für die entwicklung des klimas in den
letzten 20 jahren und das modell
präsentierte sich als äußerst
treffsicher und bildeten die jüngste
klimaentwicklung sehr gut ab das ziel
des forschungsteams aber war als
klimaschwankungen zum prognostizieren
zum vorauszusagen
die in den nächsten 15 jahren
stattfinden werden zudem sollten auch
deren schwankungen auf das klima im
großen und ganzen versackt gemacht
werden dazu das forschungsteam die
verlässlichkeit von pro card für die
jährlichen globalen mitteltemperaturen
in zeiten da waren von einem bis fünf
jahren ist nahezu perfekt und so konnten
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dann auch guten
gewissens das neu entwickelte modell
nutzen um ihre eigentliche prognose zu
erstellen
die konkrete grundfrage hier lautete wie
werden die natürlichen schwankungen die
globalen mittel temperaturen und die
meeresoberfläche temperatur von 2018 bis
2027 beeinflussen und das ergebnis ist
eindeutig kurz gesagt würde es demnach
noch bis 2022 eine warmzeit geben
konkret wird bis dahin ein natürlicher
klimatrend die menschengemachte
erderwärmung verstärken
das forschungsteam vermutet einen noch
stärkeren temperaturanstieg als es die
klimamodelle bislang vorhergesagt haben
die mitteltemperatur wird schon bis 2019
zusätzlich um 0,03 grad ansteigen und
die meerestemperaturen um 0.07 grad so
das ergebnis des modells dazu das
forschungsteam die kommende wahlperiode
ist zudem mit einer erhöhten
wahrscheinlichkeit für besonders hohe
bis extreme temperaturen verbunden
die wahrscheinlichkeit für so genannte
marine hitzewellen sei bis zum jahr 2022
sogar um bis zu 400 prozent höher
das sind hitze schübe in den weltmeeren
die schon bei einem anstieg von wenigen
graden für einige bewohner wie etwa
korallen oder seetang tödlich sein
können wenn ihr kein video verpassen
wollt auch extra videos und livestreams
nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem
kanal und nimmt auch noch ein paar
privilegien mit außerdem unterstützt sie
uns mit einem kleinen betrag einfach auf
mitglied werden klicken direkt hier
unter dem video einen riesen
die schon mitglied geworden sind das
macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den
schwankenden werbeeinnahmen wenn er
immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxer auf youtube und
er verpasst kein video einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks und social media
abonnieren
dafür jeglichen aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken hitze und
klimawandel heißt zeit bedroht erde bis
dann bleibt